People,
you know can't do with that robot just did.
I would say that's the majority of the country could never do that.
That's insane.
Play that one more time.
Yeah.
What is the name of the videos for people that are just listening to this?
Where Alison just hard core Atlit hardcore atlas.
Is that the name of the robot atlas?
That's the one going to kill us all,
but he's got a battery pack on.
Look at him just bouncing around like it's nothing.
You know?
They had some they,
they released some voice recognition from him and he was like,
I want to,
I want to murder everyone.
Most when I stop people coming on eggs.
I'm a big fan of Joe Rogan chill.
I think you had the best.
I won't rip your cock off.
Aha.
You imagine that fucking machine face to face at you like I actually enjoy you
as a person.
I won't kill you.
It's going to happen.
Oh yes.
They're going to keep doing it.
We're fucked.
When I was doing my cardio yesterday,
I was watching x Mokena.
Hmm.
That's a great fucking movie.
One of my all time favorites.
Literally watched a movie at least five times.
It scares me,
but I also am in love with it.
I love it.
But when I'm watching that movie,
I'm like,
how far away is this?
Oh,
come 20 years I,
it's gotta be less,
I think 10 years.
I think maybe a decade is when we'll have that,
but when they look like that,
that could have you seen some of the fucking molds that they've already had now?
Have you ever seen some of these,
these,
these like the molds that they can make now to make look real already?
It is scary to me.
There's a bunch of people protesting in Houston because they were about to open
up the first robot sex brothel.
Wow.
That's really interesting.
I don't think that's going to do much business.
Who wants a nut in some robot that somebody else already nut into?
I don't know how to do it a lot.
I don't know about in the United States,
but I think in overseas,
I think fucking like Japanese.
Loved that.
They love coming in robot.
We go both got a fucking robot.
How much do you get paid to be the cleaner the robot come?
Cleaner Gig.
Like dead fish
loads.
Yeah.
Washout portal for you.
Load smelled like dead fish when they sit in your underwear and steam up just
hangs out for a while or smelling.
If you jerk off and you don't clean up,
you just let it.
Whoa.
What is this sex brothel in Houston?
That's the ones actually open.
Now.
There's still discussion,
but this,
this here says that uh,
by 2020,
it will be in Houston and nine other cities.
Now did that guy make that sex robot or is he going to fuck it?
He made it any fucking it.
What do you think if you had to guess?
I think for sure that's his wife.
Here's the thing about the sex robots.
Do you think that anybody is going to make a sex robot that looks like your
average cow?
No.
Yo.
Yeah.
Well next door.
Like the next door type of girl.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah,
they will.
Well,
how many of them are going to look like this girl right here?
The exaggerated features,
90% of them will look like that at least.
Yeah.
Well a girls looked like that now anyway.
You see girls on the internet,
they all look phony a shit.
Everyone wants to have the same lips button thing.
Every girl on the internet now it looks phony ass shit.
No one looks like a chicken anymore.
But what is,
um,
what is the future going to be for?
Like when,
when it's not a human and you can do whatever you want with it,
that's when you're going to find out what people really are attracted to.
It's exactly right.
You're going to find out the real sexual psychology of humans when we find out
that there was no rules with these things.
Save all your male feminist nonsense.
I just love,
we're women with Birkenstocks.
Yeah,
yeah.
Oh yeah.
What are you fucking,
when you go to the brothel,
what are you ordering up on your Amazon sex robot?
Chia seeds.
Look at that.
How weird.
What was happening here?
So here's my biggest curiosity.
Wait a minute.
You can fuck a dude.
Fuck one of them.
I was going to get it.
I was going to get,
uh,
you know,
they have those,
um,
uh,
what are those real dolls?
They have mail,
real dolls.
I was going to get a mail real dog with no Dick and no butthole,
no mouth hall either.
Just for Jujitsu.
I was like,
listen,
you send me one,
I don't want anything.
I can fuck you.
Fuck up.
And they're like,
sure sir,
we've heard this before.
I'm going to put three bundles.
We're gonna have,
we're gonna put a bottle on its side.
I'm going to butthole and its forehead.
I just don't see a business.
I see a business for them creating personal sex robots for sure.
Nisha,
Nisha market.
I gotta tell you,
I know this is like always been a big hype for the past couple of years of like
sex robot,
sex robots and people were like,
what to do?
It's going to be the end.
It's like now people are always gonna want to fuck people.
You want to have reciprocation of something.
There's gotta be some kind of reciprocation,
you know?
And that,
do you want to fuck a dead thing like that also?
It's like it's like a feely almost.
Yeah.
Well,
yeah.
Well it's also,
you know,
there's no emotions there.
It's going to be like playing a video game on God mode,
right?
Yeah.
Your floods flawless.
Toronto's first sex doll brothel has been open for a year.
How are they doing?
The same company that's already been open there,
but how are they doing?
Fine as it is it working?
That's my curiosity.
What's the success rate of a place like this?
Why does this gross me out?
Kinky slots.
Is that what it's called?
The halls al.
I couldn't re Kinky as the adults.
Adults only.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And let me get in there Sean.
I love that you have to click.
Are you an adult?
Yeah,
I'm an adult.
Sure.
Okay.
Rent before you buy rent before you buy.
They have a loan out system will say,
but look how they all look like.
Don't any of them look like a secretary?
No.
All of them look like some super hoe.
Yeah,
right.
Like isn't there one?
Don't have like a Starbucks Barista option on.
She's kind of attractive and she's cute.
She's 3,200 look at her tit ties by body,
heat or voice.
Wait a minute.
Is that what it costs to buy?
3,230 200 bucks.
Jamie,
get one in here,
but let me see what the photos look like so we can order one order.
One.
How many people will be furious at us if we had one sitting behind me during the
show?
You would just cut another camera would cut over there to her.
Oh,
look at her gross.
Go that one when she's lying down.
Oh,
that looks so weird.
The one that you had just before.
No.
The one with her tits up in the air.
These are bizarre photos,
man.
That one.
Uh,
what?
What's that?
Stocking up.
Panic.
She looks fucking hot.
This is awful.
Stop fucking me please.
Boobs are awful.
Yeah,
it looks good.
That's wack.
It's garbage.
If you were dating a girl and you really liked her,
she just happened to have boobs like that.
You'd have to go do you?
Do you want to get those taken out?
You want to get a reduction?
I'm wanting to be like normal.
Yeah,
that looks at it looks at what is the vagina looks like.
Did they show it?
They don't show it,
but look at the waist.
Look at how fucked up that is.
That it will go back real quick.
Sorry.
That image of her waist is like,
it's like a 12 inch waist.
I mean that's fucking creepy.
Yeah,
but that's what they want.
You want like fully exaggerated features.
So going back to,
we were talking about,
you want to talk about stuff like this,
that,
that goes back to this,
um,
the core set of core said,
oh look at her waist.
And that goes back to this creepy psychology of what the figure in men's minds
socially we that like has been pushed out that you want this hourglass thing.
And did they show you video?
I want to see video looks real.
That one down where it says new.
The first new to the left.
That photo kind of looks real right there while the first one did.
Yeah.
Like,
that looks weird.
That look real for real.
Oh,
it's crazy.
Real.
Wow.
That was a girl's Instagram profile to yeah.
Yeah.
You wouldn't think twice.
She has an Instagram page.
Oh my God.
But the den again.
How many followers,
Jamie?
Look at this size of those fake tits.
There's so ridiculous.
Can you imagine following this?
What is your,
what is your wife say?
Well,
I saw that followed was styles.
Go to the upper.
Okay,
go to the right hand side.
That one with the giant tits.
That is so ridiculous.
But see Japanese,
they love that shit so hot.
I saw ha battery battery inside me.
Keep me hot.
I'm so hot.
I take off my clothes.
Why might hit so bad?
I can just hear like a Asian listeners tuning out.
Like I can't take this anymore.
Let's talk like assholes.
Assholes.
Go to the one on the upper left hand corner.
The top first.
First Image of the uh,
weight go down.
We'll get that one right there.
Look at that one.
What in the fuck man?
Like why are they so big?
Because this is what they,
I guess the idea is that the kind of people that are going to buy,
these are the kind of people that are either addicted to porn or anime porn.
And I always said that.
I would say it's because they don't get anything ever.
So they have the an I go,
click on,
click on the image one more time,
Jamie,
any of them,
any of them.
And then click on the likes.
14 likes,
Eh,
these fucking Weirdos.
Click on one of them guys.
Click on Gonzalo there.
Roland [inaudible] calling you out.
Calling you,
calling you out,
Bro.
He'll be so fucking weird dude.
Why you liking photos of doll?
That's a good job.
Good job.
Check on these guys now.
Yeah,
this is gross.
This is going to get gross.
Okay.
Just for us.
Yeah,
they don't,
people don't get to see that.
No,
but let's see if there's a video of these things moving.
This is what I want to see.
I want to see that they're just lying there.
I'm thinking that they're inanimate.
So these sex robots,
when you call them robots,
do they move?
No,
no,
no.
It's not.
No,
they're not called robots.
They're called sex dolls.
It's a doll.
I've heard about a dog,
but these are sex robot.
This has kinky doll.
These are sex dolls.
Right.
But the ones in Toronto didn't want to sense robot.
This is the same company.
So this is,
this is,
yeah,
it's just sex dolls.
So they don't move kinky Astho visible or something like that.
So I don't think they owe their posable.
Yeah,
yeah.
What he's doing,
or drip tip,
it looks really painful.
I think he's grabbing her.
Listen to me.
Let me open your mouth.
Get this off the fucking screen for I vomit.